as soon as the disaster was known very
quickly in fact the state departments
and the services of the department the
closest to the crash site and especially
the Department of alpha dog province
everybody became mobilized and I'd like
to thank them as we have done with
Chancellor and the prime minister of
Spain llamo español I would like to
thank these Jean down these fire men and
women of the civil civil servants a
military and civil personnel and also
the volunteers and the elected
representatives for the commune's
concerned it was both a rush of
solidarity and fraternity and the
movement of great efficiency
unfortunately there was no way to save
anyone since there were no survivors but
these operations mrs. allowed us to make
the site secure and to be able to
intervene in Mariano mountainous area
which is particularly difficult of
access so that everybody could be done
to preserve to preserve the bodies when
that was possible do people to preserve
the parts always destroyed aircraft that
you did so that the inquiry can give
results to the delivery time and also so
that there might be possible access for
the families just rude I would like to
state today that everything will be done
sure so that we can find identify and
give back to the families of the victims
their bodies France will also bring you
more particular
care and this is also our unknown our
hospitality do we'll pay particular care
for these so that the relatives of the
victims are not only greeted but also
supported here once again I'd like to
express my gratitude to all the people
words devotedly for this to happen I was
really moved deeply moved when I saw all
these employees gathered at repellent in
the chapel in the mortuary chapel to
greet the families one has already
arrived others are going to write and
this way we can give them information
written for comfort them and we can
welcome them and greet them in the right
way and